[Music]
it's not enough for CBS deals this
morning we have four items that may help
make your day a little easier and could
help you get a jump on those holiday
deals with gifts for your loved ones all
at exclusive low prices to start
shopping you can scan the QR code on
your screen or visit cbsdeals.com
lifestyle expert Suki Krishnan joins us
with more it is good to see you nice to
see you Jeff we've got a lot of stuff
here it is holiday crunch time so it's
time to get to business and get to
shopping what's first all right so I
love this this is called she's birdie
and this is a protective device that you
can carry on you this is something that
you can give it's a peace of mind it
doesn't look like a lot but boy it's
small and mighty are you ready to open
this really quickly uh tell the audio
guy uh just to one second
you see what this is 130 decibels
um it's got a strobe light it grabs
attention when you need attention I
think this is perfect for somebody who
works the overnight shift you just pull
the pin 130 decibels you see right there
it sounds the alarm this is perfect for
the kid who's going to school this is
perfect for a person who is actually
working an overnight shift a parent my
mom actually fell in a parking lot and
she had this and she was able to pull
the pin and get attention when she
needed how much is this one so we're
looking at 30 off we're looking at under
20. 19.99 I think this is the perfect
stocking stuffer so get to your QR code
and let's do this okay next all right we
can't look as gorgeous as you I got
wrinkles we've got wrinkles we've all
got problems thank you
um so this is perfect this is FDA
approved it's a little silicon peel
right here
um so this is made in the United States
and this is just for your under eye you
put something like this so we've got it
for your mouth your under eye your
decollete and this is called wrinkle
sminkel just basically what it says it's
peel press and remove you can see the
person right there putting it underneath
their eye their decollete you wash your
skin you put it on and you just let the
magic work and the deal right now that
we have going on anywhere from nine to
thirty five dollars a savings of 35
so I think this is a perfect gift to
give somebody who doesn't necessarily
take care of themselves but you want
them to take care of themselves or it's
a gift you can buy for yourself for a
little self-care Sunday moments knock
out those wrinkles what's next knock out
their wrinkles and cook at the same time
all right this is an award-winning gift
right here it's called pixicaid pets and
you're thinking what's in this little
box it's got everything the parent would
love and their kid can use their devices
it's stem learning right here and inside
this little book if I can open this up
and not drive the cameraman too crazy
you've got these little sheets so your
kid gets to create right here with the
markers that are also in the kit right
here they get to create a pet they
download the app and the pet actually
comes to life virtually you could put
stickers on it see right right there
they can create an arcade system it is
quite fantastic so download the app this
is an award-winning situation and we're
looking at under 15 40 off 40 off this
is something for the grandparents to
have when everybody comes home this is
something for you to have as a stocking
stuffer or just something that you can
give somebody that you love a neighbor
let me drive the cameraman crazy all the
time okay don't worry about it I'm sorry
about that I'm fidgeting around but you
know pets is one of those things that
the kids are going to want to get their
hands into
listen we're moving from virtual pets to
how about your real pets do you have a
dog out there I have a fur baby that I
love but this is a GPS tracking device
and there's lots of tracking devices
that are out there but this is actually
under a hundred dollars I'm going to
tell you the price in just a minute but
this tracking device does so much more
it actually tells the vitals of your dog
how much they ate how much they ran how
much they walk it also can teach them
tricks because it has that clicker
that's built in to this little device
which then attaches on their collar I'm
going to give you the deal right now
we're looking at 89.99 we're talking
about 60 off
Suki was nice to meet you it was really
nice to meet you John
I'm just gonna say that happy holidays a
lot tall
ER companies to get these deals to buy
anything you saw today scan that QR code
on your screen or you can head once
again to cbsdeals.com